-People always ask me if this is
something I always wanted to do,
and I feel like, to some degree,
I knew, comedy and stuff.
I feel like you knew that you
knew that you wanted to do news,
jokes about the news.
-I did. I have always --
Even when I was a little girl,
I did jokes about the news.
-And this is a photo
of a show --
a comedy show you did.
-Yes, I did.
-That you recorded
on a tape cassette.
-When I was 6 or 7 years old.
-6 or 7 years old.
-Yeah, uh-huh.
-This makes me so happy
that you knew at 6 or 7
that you wanted to record
on a tape a show called
"News for Goofs."
-Side one.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There's two sides.
-Two sides.
-Yeah, it's a tape.
-Well, the problem --
Yeah, 'cause, like,
if you listen to side two
of "News for Goofs" first,
that's all the jokes.
You miss all setup.
-Side two is the deep dive.
-And so do you still have
"News for Goofs"?
-I still have "News for Goofs."
-Are you worried about, like,
actually putting it
into a cassette player?
-I'm very worried about it.
I actually don't exactly
know how to deal with it.
There's two worries.
One is that
I'll just break the tape,
and the second worry is that
it won't be funny at all.
-Oh, but I have to imagine,
like, a 6-year-old
or a 7-year-old
doing news jokes,
how could it not be?
-I was a very shrill 7-year-old.
[ Laughter ]
-That is delightful.
You are --
You're Canadian.
You obviously have
a lot of Canadian friends.
-Yes, I do.
-Do they --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some Canada here tonight.
-Are there Canadian friends
in the audience?
We're all going out after.
-Do they kind of rub
Justin Trudeau in your face?
-Oh, of course.
Have you seen him?
-Yeah, no.
I mean, congrats.
-Yeah, I know.
He's -- Thank you.
I accept your congratulations.
That's great.
[ Laughter ]
-But, like, do you also
then feel like you maybe --
like, you finally got
this guy out there,
and then you're down here
with you-know-who?
-The contrast is remarkable.
-Yeah.
-I take a lot of heat
from my family,
'cause they still live there,
and they're like,
"Couldn't you have chosen
someone like this?"
and I'm like, "I didn't --
I didn't choose him!
I tried really hard,
and no one listened to me."
-Yeah.
-It's fine.
-I also want to --
I incorrectly assumed,
because your husband,
Jason Jones,
who was also a really funny
correspondent
on "The Daily Show."
-Thank you.
-I assumed you guys met there,
but you met years ago.
-No, we met doing regional
children's theater...
-Regional children's theater.
-...as most couples do.
[ Laughter ]
Most loving couples.
-Well, that was --
Before Tinder, that was it.
-That was --
[ Laughter ]
We played costumed characters
in a live-action remake
of the "Sailor Moon"
anime cartoon, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a very beautiful
and sexual love that we share.
-And were you guys love
interests in the show?
-We were love interests
in the show,
but we didn't
actually like each other
when we were playing
love interests.
It just kindled
a deep fire that has --
We've been together
for 20 years now.
-That's amazing.
-So it's kind of been forged...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can really
forge your relationship
in the fires of love
when you see each other, like,
changing into spandex costumes
behind a flat.
-Yeah, for kids.
-For kids.
-Also, like, "We have to do this
for children."
-For children
who hate this show.
It's bad.
[ Laughter ]
-Because when I think of who
the fans of "Sailor Moon" are,
I actually
don't think of children.
Is that wrong?
Like, I feel like older people
who like anime.
-Well, there are a lot of --
At the time, there were children
who appreciated it
on a different level.
-I just know them now as adults.
-Yeah, no, it's different now.
Things have changed.
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.